There are three cardinal
properties of frames.
The first property is that
frames represents stereotypes.
Now we all know about stereotypes.
We deal with stereotypes all the time.
Here's a stereotype for
the world eat or ate.
And this particular stereotype,
the slots are dealing with our
stereotypical, my stereotypical notion
of what happens when something is eaten.
There is a subject and it is a frog.
There is a location.
There is a time.
You may have a different
set of stereotypes.
In fact, stereotypes often
are very culture specific.
Second, frames provide default values.
So not only do they have these
slots which come from other notions
of a stereotype of this particular word,
but
many of these slots may have
values already filled in.
As an example, I may already
have a default value which says
that after the object has been eaten,
it is no longer alive.
It is inside the subject's stomach,
and the subject's mood is now happy.
There are our default values.
Of course, when you have default,
you can also have exceptions to them.
As an example,
it may be that when Ashok ate a frog,
it made him sad because frogs
don't suit him very well.
Now the exception handling is
both very powerful and a problem.
It is powerful because I can have
stereotypes or default values, and
when needed,
I can override the default values.
But it's also a problem,
because you can see what will happen.
The more instances that I have,
the more times where I'll be
overriding some default value.
And then I have to
go to worry about how to manage
all of this exceptional handling.
Nevertheless, frames provide a very nice
way of capturing both default values and
exception handling.
The third cardinal property of frames
is that they exhibit inheritance.
So I can organize this
frames in a frame hierarchy.
Here is a frame for an animal, and
then, that has two subclasses, a frame
for an ant and a frame for a human.
Note, I'm using the language of
classes and subclasses here.
Now inheritance works, in that I may
have some slot for the class animal,
and then, I may specify for the ant more
specific values for some of those slots.
For example, number of legs is six or
the number of arms is zero.
But, the important thing is that
I inherited these slots from
the super-class.
Of course,
when I specify the sub-classes,
when I go down this frame hierarchy,
I may keep on adding additional slots.
So for a human man,
we may also add the job and the name.
There's classes then we have instances,
as an example, Ashock is the name of
the person and the job is a professor.
And so, this instance is also
inheriting all these slots and
the slot values from the class.
>> We can also see that when the frames
provide default values, that's very
similar to a constructor when we're
dealing with object oriented programming
that supplies some initial values
when an object is first instantiated.
So it seems like there's actually a very
rich connection between classes and
frames here.
>> David, that's a very good point.
In fact, there is a history to it.
Frames and object-oriented
programming came about the same time,
the 1960s and the 1970s.
And I'm sure they influenced
each other in both directions.